i just want to say i'm going to give you
the space that you want
um i just hope we can still talk and
just be friends
he said what he said
mike tries to break up with ximena
after learning she's literally disgusted
by him
look she's not even like
you know just happy to be near you i
don't think
plus
mahogany am i your boyfriend or just
your friend
mahogany brings ben back down to reality
by telling him he's not her man
but even still he sets up this getaway
for them
that i'm not going to lie had me
uncomfortable as a viewer
this is beautiful it is what do you want
to eat whatever they got it's good
we'll get into that and you'll also get
a first look at my exclusive interview
with ben where i got answers to a lot of
our big questions
including this one oc wants to know
would you be comfortable with your 22
year old daughter dating a 50 year old
man
that's probably the number one question
i've gotten on my social media
uh and and they feel like that's the
ringer
let's talk about it
hey 90 day fans fam it's melisia
before we get into the musty moments
from this episode
i have to show you this awkward but
sweet moment from gino and jasmine
jasmine is teaching gino how to dance
and he has absolutely no rhythm
but she likes it
like killing ants
heal the arms baby
loose lose your body just feel this kind
of baby you're dancing like you have a
stick on your ass
just move
you know is the worst answer ever you're
so terrible
and i like it i feel like they have
turned into that wild and quirky aunt
and uncle who you know have their issues
but when they're in a good place
they can be a good time
i'm turning around with you like a thief
i have to show you that
all right let's get into mike and ximena
quick refresh
last week ximena told mike to go sleep
in the other room because she's creeped
out by the way he stares at her while
she
on top of that punch to the gut for mike
she also told him that she does not love
him
do you love me
no
surprisingly
i'm being sarcastic
ximena's blatant honesty comes after
mike refuses to pay for her plastic
surgery
and fast forward to this week ximena
pulls out
the i love you but i'm not in love with
you card
as she continues to play games with mike
playing games
ximena explains that she can't say she's
in love with mike because they haven't
lived together for a long time and love
is quote a very big word
but so is saying yes when someone
proposes
and she did that at this point mike is
confused
but he does speak up and call ximena out
on her
but you always told me that you love me
and i'm your life
tiempo
girl
we all know what ximena is doing here
it's clear as day that she does not want
mike around
but she is not ready to let go of his
benefits
[Music]
it's disappointing that she's willing to
manipulate mike and continue to lead him
on for her own comfort
as if he doesn't deserve true happiness
a couple months ago amanda was so
excited
to marry me
so when jimena tells me she doesn't love
me and
love is too big of a word
for the relationship that makes me feel
devastated even more confused mike
attempts to talk about their issues some
more
but ximena tells him
she's ready to go to bed
no she didn't
yep so he makes his way to the other
room
and here is what she has to say
[Music]
says there are things about mike that
make her uncomfortable and annoy her and
all she's doing is being honest with him
she also admits that she doesn't want to
hurt mike
meanwhile
he literally has his head in a pillow
right now
this is my thing if you know you don't
want to be with him which she knows
he's going to feel the pain at some
point so why drag it out
i mean
we know why she's doing it but still
[Music]
not really
mike sleeps it off but thankfully the
next day he calls his friend john in the
u.s
who tells him what most of us wish we
could tell him in this moment
my man i'd be out of there
you just spent countless amount of time
and energy and money to make it happen
during a pandemic who's benefiting from
everything that you were doing
her yes
mike responds by saying that he's
starting to see more and more that the
relationship is one-sided
and while ximena keeps telling him he
needs to change
she needs to remember she is not perfect
either
these are things that might that you
makes you you they're not changeable
things
her true colors are starting to come out
and usually that happens after a couple
months when you're with somebody mike
blinded by love tells his friend john
he's still hopeful things can work out
with ximena the only light at the end of
the tunnel that you need to see is the
door for the plane back to new york
facts now here is where things get
really interesting
after their conversation mike sets up a
video call with his friend nelsie who
was fluent in spanish
with hopes that she can help he and
ximena come to a better understanding of
what's going on in their relationship
and they came to a better understanding
all right
nelsie asks ximena what she likes about
mike and instead of naming those things
she started to list what she doesn't
like about mike she even called him
degenerate
m
look she's not even like you know just
happy to be near you i don't think
right
obviously the situation is making ximena
miserable too
now nelson's next question
lands her on the wall of 90 day mvps
we can go ahead and put mike's friend
john up there too
yes this wall is dedicated to the voices
of reason that are so needed in this
90-day world
they don't come around often so we have
to show love when they do
all right back to nelson's question
that's the one
hey
michael you didn't tell me that before
what happened when you guys met she
stopped working and then you've been
basically supporting her and her her
kids and her and
paying her rent and all everything
is that what you've been doing
yes nelsie ends the conversation by
telling mike that she hopes he stops
paying for ximena stuff
she's literally disgusted by you
and i don't think she's happy with you
and i don't think that she has love for
you i just want to ask ximena if mike's
financial assistance is worth all this
stress personally i would rather work
and have peace of mind than deal with
somebody i don't want to be around
because they support me financially
granted it's not that black and white
for everybody some people feel as if
they have to do what they have to do but
at least respect the person that's
giving you a hand the reality is she
needs mike mike doesn't need her
i just want to say i'm going to give you
the space that you want
um i just hope we can still talk and
just be friends
to be real ximena's words give me
flashbacks
to the no good men i have left in my
past
what do you mean are you ending things
with me
once again
i said what i said now mike has to
muster up the strength to say yes i'm
ending it with you and based off the
tease for next
week i don't know if he has it in them
she said i could stay and see if we
could come up with a solution
because she wants you to pay for stuff
she doesn't deserve you being around and
you don't deserve to be treated like
that it's tomorrow all right
what do you think is mike going to leave
does he have the strength
this is his first serious girlfriend
probably not
but we'll see
mike surprise me please i'm looking at
some texts just reminding myself that it
was real
like i'm not crazy
all right on to ben and mahogany
the day after she lied about where she
lives and ben found out she's truly 22
and not 24. she's something that kind of
caught me off guard he decides not to
confront her about her lies
instead he feels as if they need more
time to bond so he meets up with her and
two of her friends
who clearly feel uncomfortable having
this 52 year old man around
him
her one friend said she never would have
imagined mahogany going out with someone
almost as old as their parents
who at their age early 20s
some friends will surprise you
you think you know somebody and then
they just come out the woodworks with
something and have you wondering
who are you really
but then again it is early 20s most of
us had no clue who we were all right
back to ben
can you tell me something about mahogany
that you love about her
he starts asking mahogany's friends
questions about her come on
[Music]
is very responsible and this is the
person that you can always trust and
count on oh
it's beautiful wait did anyone catch
mahogany's reaction
she speaks spanish so
i'm not sure why she's acting as if the
translator just helped her understand
what her friend said trust and count
on oh
it's beautiful
maybe she's nervous
anyway
ben goes on to ask this
can you tell me something that
you want me to know as her new boyfriend
well honestly i didn't think you were
her boyfriend but she did tell us she
had a friend from abroad coming to visit
her
oh the silence
ben goes on to ask mahogany if he is her
boyfriend and she responds by saying
i never told you that i think bran you
never told me oh mahogany do you want to
be my girlfriend
this leads ben to face the fact that he
just assumed
[Music]
here we had been planning a family
together planning on getting married
having very intimate conversations
i traveled 4 000 miles to be with her
and all of a sudden i'm not even her
boyfriend
i am so shocked i just don't quite
understand where she's coming from
i'm just really confused by the whole
thing ben needs to be smarter in this
dating game
it is 2022. it can be ruthless out here
he's a bit too naive which is something
i asked him about during our chat we
learned about your childhood experience
you grew up in a very strict religious
home
do you think that that had that has
anything to do with um you being naive
when it comes to dating and being so
i guess optimistic about people and
overlooking red flags do you think that
has anything to do with it
there probably is um i have been in
therapy for a year and a half i went
through a dating
um
time in my life that i just was not
happy with it was just not good my first
marriage just was so disastrous that i
felt like you know am i just trying to
start all over you know and and dating
someone so young you know is me trying
to you know just capture those years
back
ben goes on to say that he doesn't think
that's the case with mahogany
but it's definitely something he's
thought about let's quickly touch on
this getaway which starts off with an
awkward car ride
when they get to the hotel they go into
their separate rooms
so tomorrow sand dunes
yes perfect okay sounds good
and the next day they set out to have
some fun in the desert
which includes a dinner where ben gets a
little
touchy philly
this is beautiful it is what do you want
to eat whatever they got it's good
while that relationship makes many of us
uncomfortable specifically with their
age difference ben being 52 in mahogany
being 22 the truth of the matter is that
she's legal i know that doesn't take the
uneasiness out of it but
it is what it is
all right here is ben's answer to the
big question everyone wants to know
oc wants to know
would you be comfortable with your 22
year old daughter dating a 50 year old
man
right and you know that's probably the
number one question i've gotten on my
social media
uh and and they feel like that's the
ringer like oh man if he can actually
that's a good question we're good yeah
absolutely and there's no one that loves
mahogany more
in this world than her dad i would hope
that the gentleman the 50 year old would
have the same exact rules that i have
and that is he has to go through me
and i interview him and i look at him
and i look at his health
i look at his viability i look at his
context i look at his background i look
at his intentions
and you know would there be a chance
that i'd ever let them date i don't know
it would really have to depend on the
individual
he said a lot more but of course i can't
include it all here but it is a must
watch check out
etonline.com and our youtube channel for
the full interview all right next week
we are getting back into kim and usman
it looks like things are continuing to
go south in their relationship after
usman told kim the truth about zara
why would you bring me down here to
shoot a video about another woman this
is 40.
very funny
funny too
kim said you are not about to play me on
tv
alright 90 day fans fam make sure you
stick with e.t because we are covering
it all i will see you next time
[Music]